une partie des juifs français sont
originaires du maghreb parmi elles la
langue arabe c'est quasiment éteinte
mais certains décide d'apprendre voire
de consacrer leur vie à la langue qui
fut celle de leurs ancêtres nommant avec
une identité remontant au vième siècle
avant jésus-christ sofiane aubin et
terminale titane sont allés à leur
rencontre
reportage est là il s'agira
elle amène annaba cana cool
j ai jéronimos l'hymne h tout marron et
celle là me choquera pour gérard
anne-marie fragile hors enseignants
johan l'arabe revêt un caractère intime
ils descendent des communautés juive de
tunisie et d'algérie
ce cours est dispensé par l'association
dallas là elle a été co fondée à paris
par yohann taïeb pour raviver les
cultures juives maghrébine elles se sont
exprimées au travers de la langue arabe
pendant près de treize siècles j'ai
l'impression de compléter ce que
j'aurais dû faire qu'on fait est déjà là
bas et qu'on n'a pas fait parce que
la vie qu'on menait le système colonial
ne favorisait pas l'apprentissage de
l'arabe sous ce système colonial un
cousin de gérard devient pourtant
professeur d'arabe et y consacre sa vie
il n'est autre que le père d'anne marie
à sa mort elle hérite de son immense
bibliothèque un désir net en elle
comprendre la langue qui fascinait son
père
et oui j'en ai encore quelques-uns
j'avais besoin qu'il ya quelque chose
d'abord qui s'ancre en moi de cet
héritage même si ça pouvait pas être
forcément à prendre tout ça et c'est je
ne pouvais pas m'en défaire
l'enfance dannemarie a été bercée par
une langue qu'elle ne comprenait pas
je l'avais entendu parler beaucoup et
comme j'avais quand même cette musique
se sont en moi
le fait de déchiffrer c'est comme quand
on connaît une chanson on peut là la
fredonner mais si on lit exactement la
partition on va on va découvrir d'autres
choses enfin c'est une mise en musique
en fait par hasard anne-marie rocroi
gérard son cousin éloigné lors de leur
premier cours d'arabe depuis ils
progressent ensemble l'occasion aussi de
replonger dans leur histoire familiale
il y a quelques années anne marie s'est
décidé à visiter l'algérie de leurs
ancêtres maintenant je peux parler un
peu autrement dans ces années là et toi
tu es né au web à moi je suis né en
algérie mais je connais pas et j'avais
envie de deux touchés
j'avais envie de voir et que ce soit pas
juste un fantasme ce pays j'étais
anxieuse aller tout seul quand même
voilà j'ai un collègue qui m'a mis en
contact avec un autre collègue algérien
qui ont fait que j'ai pu être vraiment
accueilli comme une petite reine
avec l'indépendance algérienne l'exode
des juifs ont entamé de longue date ce
accélère brutalement
gérard avait 25 ans lorsqu'il est arrivé
en france il n'a jamais voulu retourner
en algérie depuis jeudi gérard voilà je
t'appelle parce que je vais aller
bientôt en algérie et j'ai entendu au
bout du fil
j'ai entendu ça
je ne peux pas venir
parce que la première chose que je ferai
ce serait d'aller au cimetière me
recueillir sur la tombe de ceux qui sont
restés là bas
et dans l'état où se trouvent les
cimetières à annaba en particulier c'est
même pas pensable je pense que ce que
moi j'ai vécu n'existe plus voilà
la famille paternelle de johan et judéo
tunisienne mais avant de transmettre la
langue arabe aux autres lui aussi a dû
la faire sienne une quête d'abord
incomprise
ma famille avec mon rapprochement avec
le monde arabe et sa langue avec peur
naturellement et elle a d'abord refusé
awa cheikh
quand j'ai décidé d'aller en egypte pour
y vivre un an mon père s'y est opposé et
ma mère étaient inquiètes et il y avait
de quoi mais j'y suis allé quand même
après ma réussite à l'agrégation d'arabe
les choses ont changé au sein de ma
famille
ils ont compris que je pouvais être juif
et arabe
donc il a cogné roux dit
ouah
[Musique]
présenter l'héritage une et orientale
comme l'un des visages de la culture
arabe tel est l'esprit de cette
exposition proposée par lima à paris
gérard tenait à y emmener ses deux
petits enfants
tu te rends compte que tu as des
couvertures pour les fêtes juives tiges
et on recouvre le pas avec des dans
lequel il il représentait la mosquée
d'omar sy te dire à quel point on est on
était dans une éco cool la relation est
tellement différente de celle
d'aujourd'hui aujourd'hui ce semblerait
totalement impensable de banlieue où il
ya vraiment une scission pour le coup
entre les deux il ya une limite en
affrontement un petit peu hostile et
d'ailleurs de vouloir réconcilier cette
vision plus anciennes ou en fait c'est
une culture qui se suivent et qui sont
proches l'une de l'autre s'est en fait
aujourd'hui on parle de barrières mais
c'est un peu absurde là c'est ce qu'on
voit dans l'expo sécu la culture c'est
ça a été la même pendant des années et
petit à petit et des séparations le but
ce sera peut être dire faire tomber les
barrières ou casser les barrières mais
juste revenir là où il y en avait pas
quoi pour elliott la langue arabe n'est
pas seulement une rencontre avec l'autre
mais aussi un retour à ses propres
racines judéo arabe
à battant ainsi un mur factice
[Musique]
et tout de suite tour d'horizon de
l'actualité sportive 1